and now you have
now the dolphins
apparently are still going to limit it
to 13 000 for their next home game on
october 25th so still just 13 000.
right but now you got statewide stadium
uh restrictions are being removed in
florida
meanwhile i mean help me help me with
this so stefan gilmore test positive
from the patriots there's the photos
going around
of how close gilmore and patrick mahomes
were after their monday night after the
game catch up you know the whole thing
face to face two more titans
i believe it is two
uh tested positive
there it is a loss there it is
finally a las vegas raider finally
let me say that again
about time a las vegas raider tested
positive giving out how much they've
been playing around with kobe 19.
um
yeah what do you make all the covic
chaos
uh that's going on today specifically
within the nfl
okay uh i got a few things on this mike
let's start with florida i'm not
surprised
that this is a florida story with hey
you're going to get permission to have
65 000 people
in a stadium that wouldn't make any kind
of sense
and i don't know
if people if you have the if you have
the opportunity if you're a dolphins fan
i mean good for them you know yeah root
for the team they're one and three again
uh it's more of their future not their
present but let's say you want to
support the team would you do it would
you be in a stadium with 60 000 plus
other people would you really do that
uh and if you would why
so that's a crazy story
but really we look at stefan gilmore
and you look at the titans and you look
at the raiders and you look at john
gruden who may have like some kind of
does he have like some kind of mental
block
when it comes to
masking up does he have an issue
but with all these things i say to you
mike if the nfl
if you're not gonna have a bubble
what are you gonna do
if the bubble if the bubble is not
reasonable
if the bubble can't be pulled off
what are you gonna do because the only
other solution it seems like
is just to shut it down just to shut it
down no
no that's not happening you know that's
not happening like i think i think it
just is what it is
and maybe you know
those of us who are trying to live in
the real world and still adhering to
socially distant practices and and my
kids are
distance learning and my wi-fi going out
in the morning and it was just like you
know
dad i got kicked off my meeting like
what you want me to do it was like
you're too right
you know yeah it's just you know who's
watching
devices devices i i'm trying to do
something here no more devices those
those of us who are living in the real
world trying to hunker down so that we
can get through this together are just
going to have to
just
listen get through our frustration get
through our frustration with watching
the nfl act like we're not in the midst
of a pandemic because if we want we
can't we can't we can't have it both
ways michael we can't be like yo
you know it's good to have sports back
we want our entertainment the nfl is is
explicitly saying and expressly saying
it is what it is they're not trying to
avoid positive covet tests matter of
fact there was a statement from the
nfl's doctor to that effect earlier this
afternoon they're not trying to avoid
covet tests they're trying to mitigate
the spread as best they can all right
here it is in the nine weeks since the
beginning of training camp we have had a
number of isolated new positive cases of
covenant among players and other
personnel across nearly two thirds of
nfl clubs and one outbreak among the
titans i'll come back to the titans in a
second michael holly
we've said all along that they expect
positive tests
but all they're trying to do
is use the protocols
uh to quickly identify new cases get
individuals the care they need and
prevent further spread of the virus um
bottom line is yada yada
bottom line is man
they're saying hey the protocols are
designed to protect or prevent the
spread of people from getting infected
it's going to happen the question is
what do we do when and if it does and
how do we stop it from having enough of
an outbreak to what we do we do have to
shut it down because all we have to do
is come to grips with as a
fan as fans as observers something that
the league has already basically said
this is going to be a year full of
inconsistencies and inconveniences
everybody is not going to play 16 games
this is not going to be a normal 17-game
uninterrupted schedule the bubble
allowed the nba to finish its season
with its uh competitive balance intact
that's not what's gonna happen here the
titans man
you're right it did it you know
let's just get over the idea that's
being normal this is not going to be it
allowed it allowed the nba to finish
with this competitive balance intact but
that is not why
the nba wanted to finish the season they
got what they wanted they wanted hey the
game is on abc and espn they were able
to fulfill those tv contracts and tnt
and all the partnerships that they have
and that's what and that's what the nfl
is trying to do right now look it's a
very complicated dance and i'm not
trying to say like it's not so easy it
is complex it's not so easy to say good
guys over here bad guys over here
because some of the people that we would
consider good guys because i naturally
go with the with the rank and file the
millionaire ranking file in this case
the players i naturally kind of lean
with them
so they're the good guys but they're
also
trying to make some money like they
don't want it to be shut down because
that's income like imagine your your
industry say it's easy for us to say hey
shut the whole thing down but we're not
in that industry so if you're trying to
make some money you want to keep it
going you want to keep yourself safe and
your family safe
but
there's still games to be played and
like how do you handle it like what new
england did let's just let's be honest
let's be honest
if money were not a factor
if you have one player
your quarterback has coveted
there's no way in the world
you're getting on a plane in a couple of
days right you're playing against two
planes you're not doing two planes two
planes two planes
and i told you
i told you they're flying the plane
while they build it literally okay but
no you could have stopped right there if
money weren't a factor if money weren't
a factor and you ported this out ad
nauseam about the ivy league if money
were not a factor they wouldn't be
trying to do this right so it's not just
about if money weren't a factor yes the
patriots would not have continued on the
kansas city incubation period be damned
when it comes to covet i mean nobody's
surprised that has followed the research
and the science about covert 19 that a
player from the patriots tested positive
when the incubation period is anywhere
from what five to 14 days before you
have enough of a viral load to test
positive i mean right of course somebody
tested positive and i don't know what's
happened l is shocked
what's going to happen what's going to
happen on sunday they got a game on
sunday against denver and some people
say hey you know is ken cam being here
we don't know what cam's condition is
the type of the team they're gonna have
to forfeit because the titan they
probably have to forfeit because the
titans michael first of all like
shout out to cam hey listen to cam
newton hey you know what i want to say
this just so somebody can say that they
said it listen to can't quarterback cam
newton over the president of the united
states
cam newton knows better than the
president of the united states take your
cues from cam newton i just wanted to
say that real quick i also want to say i
also want to say i want that jacket okay
oh yeah where can i find this
where can i find that where can i find
that i want it okay come on hook your
brother up cam now listen let's talk
about
that that's it fresh as always let's
talk about the titans though because i
mentioned this yesterday i mentioned it
in passing and it's widely reported
today the titan i thought i told you
just don't know if you caught it the
titans
were having
private workouts among players
after they had been sent home
after they've been sent home with the
positive test they were having private
workouts so they're being investigated
for violating the protocols which are
being put in place again not to prevent
testing positive but to try to eliminate
and catch it and try to you know stick
some fingers and holes in the dams is
best that the nfl can and so i think
that's all they can do short of a bubble
which i've said at nauseam is not
logistically feasible and it probably
isn't it probably is sort of a bubble
this is all they could do is
listen i hate to quote the president but
the nfl is actually
the nfl is actually doing what the
president is saying trying to learn to
live with it learn to just accept it
this is the reality and the reality
might be some the titans the titans are
their facility is shut down again today
how did the bills play the titans on
sunday i believe they're up next when
there's a thursday night game against
the chiefs after that sorry tennessee
y'all
y'all might be undefeated on the field
but y'all gonna take this l thanks to
kovit hey listen listen uh uh chris sims
said that and we'll talk talk with him
this week chris sims said look
you might have to start slapping some
elves on people you might just have to
take an l
just because it's not perfect but it may
be the way to go but that's not what i
was going to say i was going to say dr
jason johnson he's so great uh
and you always learn something talking
to him how about his his little nugget
about the constitution
the constitution is a gentleman's
agreement now that we know that some
things have been exposed there but
one thing i meant to ask him
and and uh and i didn't get a chance to
but i'll ask you and the answer may be
obvious but i'm just trying to
do a little uh just follow the paper
trail here
when did
when did all of this become political
when did wearing a mask
become
a political thing when did you know
social distancing when did this turn
from hey we're in a pandemic
and you hear about what's going on
in wuhan you hear about what was
happening in italy and it shut down the
entire country this is before it came to
us
when did it become from where did it go
from hey we got to do this thing we got
to prepare for it to
well if you're wearing a mask you're
probably a liberal
and if you're not wearing a mask you
believe in your personal freedom like
when did that happen
i don't know i don't know exactly when
but we but we know why we know why um
i've been saying like it's it because it
has trickled mike i believe this it has
trickled into the nfl i think some some
people are just getting it just because
i'm not blaming people who are getting
it some people are getting it just
because but i go back to john gruden
again is john gruden not wearing a mask
because he's one of those hey a mask
doesn't help you people or is he so
caught up in the moment he's so i don't
know he's so i don't know he's so fired
up about coaching that hey
like i said yesterday if i were the nfl
i wouldn't i wouldn't even care what his
reason was i would sit him down i'd
suspend him i'd be like you know what go
home and think about it go home and and
if you don't want to wear a mask stay
home
that was simple and plain i wouldn't i
would be giving these warnings and
sternly worded memos to a guy that's got
a 100 million dollar contract like you
think he cares about your fines you know
and you want to talk about like and his
team okay he's about to trickle down his
team is taking his cues from him
because you know along with the titans
the raiders best to my knowledge have
been as irresponsible as any team in the
league when it comes to to to the
protocols i mean just generally speaking
and you're right about you know the
constitution observation
is
just going back to that point real quick
the so-called gentleman we know about
the founding fathers but the so-called
gentleman who came up with this
agreement it was the the president was
supposed to represent the best of us us
but also in air quotes
they didn't they didn't account for the
worst of us ascending to the presidency
so that's why this whole thing this
whole thing blew up uh in their face but
going but bringing it full circle full
circle to ron desantis saying that
stadium restrictions have been lifted
maybe that's what it's all about you
keep saying follow the money are nfl
teams serious about the season or are
they serious about what roger goodell
said a long time ago at the beginning of
this pandemic is we want full stadiums
you know are they looking at it like yo
one way or the other we need people we
need butts in these seats because while
while florida is opening up to full
capacity
time after time you're seeing more and
more fans in these stands so clearly
it's not enough just for the games to be
televised televised and for the games to
go off they seem to want this to be as
normal as possible so it's not just that
you got to text protecting themselves
look at where the fans are now being
subjected to announcements being subject
to subjecting themselves to the danger
that they're putting themselves in
hey hey mike they're just gonna have to
take one they're gonna have to take this
speaking of taking l's
the nfl is going to have to take this l
and just say
it's not going to happen the way we want
it to now when roger goodell took over
as commissioner way back man he's been
this is like what 14 years ago now man
it's been a while time goes fast when he
took over as commissioner he was like
hey
we got to get our revenue up to the 25
billion billion not million 25 billion
mark
and they're they're more than halfway
there now
so
it was very um
it was visionary on his part because i'm
thinking man
they're not gonna make they're not gonna
reach 25 billion they are they're gonna
get there
they've got the best tv deal in north
america if you are an nfl owner even if
you paid a record amount for your team
you're doing all right before you open a
gate before you sell a parking space
before you sell a hot dog
or jersey life is good for you as an nfl
owner so this year it's not going to be
so good but as aaron rodgers said even
they're bad is good
so they're gonna have to take this mic
and i think
you're not gonna have you're not gonna
have full stadiums you shouldn't have 65
000 in miami 68 000 in new england 70
plus thousand in buffalo it's just not
going to happen it's a pandemic adjust
we're not getting a bubble i can tell
you that stop with the bubble talk you
might right you might be right that's
tough that's a tough one to pull off
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports